hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm going to answer a question
from one of my face book readers John
who wrote in asking me to get his get my
thoughts on one of his recent blog posts
its target for SEO value to begin a real
estate investors and one of my thoughts
and I promised him that I would create a
video reply so let's go check out his
page and see what we think so limited up
here so this article the five
fundamental five fundamentals successful
real estate investing in Canada so at
first glance it looks like a
professional website is great good
layout good design scrolling through the
article it looks it looks professionally
done and easy to read so it's good that
you separate it up here with different
points most people are scanners at the
beginning when they first read an
article so you know you don't want just
one big block attacks it's nice to split
this up you might want to experiment
here with making these a little bit
bigger just makes it easier to scan so
you know try increasing the font size
it'll make it look just a little bit
nicer but that's that's a minor point
I'm not going to comment too much on a
text because it's not something that I'm
you know super interested in myself but
i'm sure people who are interested it's
professionally done some minor things
here i guess looking at the design
there's something off here where your
your titles going to the next bar and
it's hard to read this cut off by this
this extra line here again a minor thing
what I might do you want to always make
sure there's a call to action so this is
great here if you're kind of joining us
you might want to put this in bold so
again that stands out clicking on the
website hopefully this goes to your page
and there's some landing page here this
just goes back to the blog to the
article okay so this is something i
would definitely fix right you're saying
if you're tuned in joining other
like-minded investment partners click
here you want this to land somewhere
where it's talking about joining other
like
Investment Partners so it just fix up
that link so it's not just going to the
same post that I just read it's not
really offering me a lot of extra value
here if you want people to take the next
step you might also consider giving them
some kind of free whitepaper free
download here the ideas you want people
to stay on your side a little bit longer
showcase you as an expert and let them
know that you know what you're posting
is truthful stuff and that you're the
guy to go to for this kind of
information so they'll they're more
likely to read a little bit more before
calling you so if you had some kind of
white paper here to talk about
opportunities or if you had related
posts if you posted other content on
this blog put it under here so that you
can get people clicking spending more
time on your site and the longer they do
that the more likely they are going to
take that next up and want to sign up
with you I didn't see who this Cantus
article was by so again if you're trying
to showcase yourself as an expert you
probably want to showcase your name and
your picture somewhere here so it says
posted by content so that's that's
probably not good you know if you wrote
this and be posted by John or you know
somebody on your team you know put the
name put the picture again seeing a face
makes it more personable it'll be you
know people more likely to trust it this
is written by somebody that they can
ideally relate to so I definitely put
your name and your picture on there as
well but overall pretty good a lot
better than a lot of the sites out there
but hopefully those quick tips help you
make this blog even better so thanks for
everybody for watching if you liked the
video I'd really appreciate if you want
to give it a thumbs up and if you have
any thoughts about this article or you
have a question about your website that
you want to check out make sure you
leave a comment underneath the video and
we'll see you on the next episode
you